est ce que vous êtes passé à côté de ses
smartphones ces smartphones enfin on
dirait ce smartphone vous voyez taille
en a qu'un série limite gt2 banon ces
smartphones ont fait de la magie si on
les multiplie je multiplie pas les pas
moi je multiplie les boîtes de
smartphones et ça c'est plutôt bien
alors aujourd'hui on parle de quoi on
parle dur il me gt2 et surtout j'étais
de pros le gt2 frau il n'intéresse
pourquoi parce que ça c'est une super
promesse que nous a fait cette marque là
avec un smartphone haut de gamme très
haut de gamme hyper spe pour être hyper
sérieux pour être hyper v ner et faire
un truc de dingue on va regarder
seraient ils me jettent et de pros ce
qui peut faire on va regarder qu'est ce
qu'il raconte on va regarder ce qu'ils
racontent par rapport au rytme gt2 qui
illustre un petit peu en dessous mais
surtout ce truc là là ça fait super
promesses et c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo
qui a réalisé en partenariat avec reed
mirilli m'a dit tiens monsieur greuet ce
que tu veux tester et découvrir nos
nouveaux modèles gt 2 gt2 prendre remy
on va y aller alors c'est pas
[Musique]
regarder perd pas de temps ah on ouvre
tac tac tac tac le smartphone up là haut
up là haut up là-haut plat il est dans
la boîte il est la tour de magie paf le
vol à regarder alors j'aime bien déjà le
parti pris est un truc un peu différent
soyez parce que dans le monde du
smartphone ya beaucoup de choses qui se
ressemblent bougeait pas ce que je vais
arrêter mon truc et bien droit quand
même on est droit on est à vous est
comme ça vous savez vous faire un
torticolis dans le monde des smartphones
ya beaucoup de smartphones qui se
ressemblent et on va de plus passé peu
de temps il ya vachement de marquer
disent tiens si on essaie façon un peu
différente se démarquer et là ils vont
vraiment là dessus au niveau de la
petite signature vous retrouver sur le
coteau sur le couteau non sur le côté
pas sur le coton vous aurez compris que
tout ça ne sait comment aider alors on a
un touché qui assez rigolo c'est à
toucher un peu papier c'est ce qu'ils
ont voulu faire un toucher très très
d'où l'idée de se toucher doux c'est
qu'ici on va pas du tout prendre de
traces de doigts donc c'est plutôt bien
ce soit pas très joli un point coup
maintenant le truc c'est que on va pas
ici pouvoir le recharger sans fil donc
ici on n'aura pas de recharge sans fil
et ça il faut le savoir trois caméras ok
on y revient dans quelques instants le
petit bouton pour venir l'allumé pour
atteindre alors ce petit bouton et un
truc aussi qui est très sympa je pense
que vous le verrez bien c'est qu'en fait
il ya un petit côté grippe lorsque je le
touche je senti une petite accroche une
petite rugosité au niveau de mon doigt
donc ça ça fonctionne c'est plutôt pas
mal sur le dessus j'ai quoi le petit
micro pour la réduction de bruit ici les
boutons de volume qui eux n'ont pas de
côté grippe et sont plutôt lisse tiroirs
de cartes sim recharge en usb c'est le
petit haut parleur qui se situe là donc
voilà c'est assez simple c'est assez
mignon à l'intérieur de la boîte qu'est
ce que je vais retrouver encore des
fuites show expérience intéressante a
dit nous aurions petit message c'est
blanc sur le banc ça c'est ça c'est
ballot j'ai bien vu leurs ennemis de
faire du blanc semblant comme ça on peut
rien dire de fioul tube in people in pé
pa pa il se paie pas une pipe en fait je
n'aime pas le dire en fait ils ont
vachement beau c'est leur emballage pour
avoir un côté éco responsable et pour ne
pas venir polluer donc ça c'est plutôt
bien et nous fait donc c'est très très
cool pour moi quand une petite coque à
l'arrière signèrent il me toujours
pareil il y aurait de la grosse recharge
bien fat ça c'est de la super d'arte
c'est écrit noir sur blanc faisait pas
besoin de moi pour vous le dire mais
c'est la 65 watts alors c'est assez
intéressant parce que ça vous leur
charge de 0 à 100% en 33 minutes donc sa
bataille relativement vite vous avez
votre câble ici le rechargement en usb à
usb c'est ok et puis voilà on a fait
tourner un petit lapin donc voyez un peu
ce cas au niveau de cette boîte l'a
alors ça est sensiblement la même chose
sur le gt2 nous on va vraiment faire un
gros focus sur le fêter deux pros et on
s'engagera ce gt by devrait peser
instants alors laissez moi juste le
paramétrer sentir un petit tour de magie
et puis ensuite on va regarder tout vous
dire en détail ça c'est cool regardez ça
c'est vrai que c'est assez marrant parce
que lorsque je les prends comme ça je me
dis lequel il prend lequel n'est pas pro
c'est qui se ressemble vachement leur
après on te souhaite un peu la
différence celui-là c'est le pro ils
sont un peu plus proche l'impression
qu'ils sont un peu plus grand quoique
c'est juste au niveau de la disposition
des 60 vachement donc ce procès celui là
on se concentre sur le présent le prog
hard et parce que moi ce projet
m'intéresse bien pourquoi parce qu'à
plusieurs choses à voir déjà vous avez
un capteur d'empreintes digitales vous
posez votre doigt sa déverrouille c'est
très pratique c'est très rapide le truc
qui m'a fait marrer jimmy est tombé n'y
a pas de fonder creusot qui met un petit
fond d'écran assis au fond d'écran enfin
c'est pour avoir un espèce de côté un
peu chez basse et papiers matière c'est
assez marrant alors ça m'a fait penser
vraiment à ce qu'on a au dos voyez ce
côté matière un peu nature qu'on vient
trouver ici sur un vrai choix un vrai
parti pris ici alors après on peut bien
changer un vous avez qu'à laisser poser
votre doigt comme ça et vous allez au
fond d'écran et à des fonds d'écran au
pelage accepte j'autorise doit y en
avoir des tonnes de toutes les couleurs
d animer des pas animé décidé ça et on
va se mettre quoi nous à se mettre ça
hop là c'est joli ça bouge c'est sympa
on se levait pour les deux et ça me va
bien comme je saurai me why 3.0 basé sur
android 12 vous avez de la
personnalisation pour apporter des
couleurs d'icônes cordes bouton qui vont
être vraiment lié à votre smartphone
donc on peut venir personnalisé voyez
c'est pratique c'est sympa on vient
personnalisés aujourd'hui ces couleurs
aller moi ça me va bien et hop je
reviens là je vois des choses
personnalisé et ça c'est quand même
plutôt cool voici le premier truc qui
m'intéresse c'est ce grand écran 6,7
pouces avec une résolution de cas de
casser quoi c'est du wqs des plus et
surtout ici c'est une dalle super amoled
ça veut dire quoi une dalle super amoled
ça veut dire que lorsque vous allez
venir et bien tac tac dans les
paramètres hop là je viens ici par
exemple je viens ensuite au niveau de
mon affichage et luminosité et que je me
mets en thèmes sont hélas ça veut dire
que tout ce qui va être noir c'est du
pixel est un donc ça c'est bien ça va
jouer pour l'économie de la batterie et
ça va jouer aussi sur un autre point qui
est vachement intéressant c'est des
noirs profonds c'est un taux de
contraste et on appellera un fini par
vraiment a fini en tout cas très très
très très très élevé versus du scd donc
ça c'est vachement cool et en plus ici
c'est une dalle ltp au 2.0 alors ça veut
dire quoi cette histoire ltp ok mais en
fait c'est pareil on revient dans les
paramètres je vous montre en fait que
c'est le taux de rafraîchissement
variable si vous allez ici dans votre
affichage améliorer la netteté d'image
donc on peut venir le faire il ya pas
mal de petites techno qui sont assez
intéressante ici améliorer la couleur
vidéo on améliore tous les fous furieux
améliorer le mouvement on peut venir
améliorer le mouvement pour apporter un
peu plus de fluidité le confort des yeux
alors la résolution de l'écran par
défaut elle est en full hd + 1 mais
regardez vous venez vous l'a passée
directement vous en wqs des plus alors
ça va consommer davantage au niveau de
la batterie mais bon pour la démo je
vous le mets comme ça et puis surtout à
fréquence d'actualisation c'est un taux
d'actualisation de votre écran il va
être soit en automatique comme ça soit
en élevé soit en standard standard 60
hertz ok classique et lever 120 hertz ça
veut dire que si vous passez en lvc du
120 hertz tout le temps moi ce que je
vous conseille c'est de rester pour
sélectionner automatiquement parce que
c'est justement l'intérêt que sa
technologie ltp au 2.0 c'est un taux de
rafraîchissement variable et lui valent
gérer directement entre 1 jusqu'à 120
hertz si vous regardez par exemple un
film qui en 25 images/seconde assure 85
m si par exemple sur un oiseau displayed
vous serez sûr du 1er août et si vous
scrollé comme un dingue où se trouvaient
de faire du gaming 120 hertz vous
absolument aucun problème et ça va
vraiment apporter de la fluidité ça
vraiment apporté à l'expérience
utilisateur en plus ici vous avez des
couleurs 10 bits ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire un milliard de couleurs un
écran qui en plus est certifié yaris
plus est avec un pic de luminosité
qu'une luminosité maximale à 1400 dit
autant vous dire que là lorsque vous
êtes dehors franchement il ya de quoi
faire si je vous tous à fond là alors je
sais qu'au travers d'un écran 7 à
évident de se rendre compte mais c'est
quand même extrêmement lumineux donc si
vous voulez vous balader l'été profiter
vraiment de beaucoup de lumière si vous
êtes en extérieur qui a beaucoup de
soleil ça ira ya pas de souci et une
gamme colorimétrique 100% petrohawk est
haut parleurs stéréo avec un
haut-parleur la la si la scène
principale et l'autre c'est celui là
vous avez donc ça monsieur pallandre
enfants il a un petit côté
spatialisation mais s'en vient renforcer
une somme va bien on a un smartphone qui
est certifié à erez et on a du bluetooth
5.2 et en plus il est compatible dolby
et mousse alors l'autre truc qui est
intéressant dans ce smartphone l'axé qui
si vous avez un sa dragonne 8 jean wan
jen un joyau jane ne serait plus logique
huit des nains que huit john wayne c'est
bizarre à gaza dragon huit gènes 1 ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on a les
derniers processeurs de qualcomm qui va
vous apporter beaucoup de performances
pour venir jouer par tourner tous les
jeux vous voulez dessus vous aura
absolument aucun problème après vous
avez le choix au niveau de la
configuration de la rame soit 8 soit 12
ziad race et la lpddr2 donc derrière
techno sa tartine ça m'a vachement bien
et vous avez soit 128 soit 256 go de
stockage en nuage est trois points
devant c'est pareil c'est à très vite en
lecture et en écriture donc ici vous
avez les dernières techniques
permettront d'avoir un smartphone
extrêmement rapide si vous êtes gamer
vous avez vraiment ce qu'il faut que ce
qui convient donc la dernière est super
pour le multimédia mais également pour
le gaming le taux d'échantillonnage
tactile qui va jusqu'à 1000 hertz pro
gaming c'est top la fréquence
d'actualisation qui va jusqu'à 120 hertz
aussi pour le gaming c'est top la
performance derrière bref c'est top vous
avez une très grosse batterie de 5000
militants paiera donc ça aussi c'est
vachement bien et je vous les digues de
la recharge rapide 65 watts autant dire
qu'ici vous avez incombe aux gagnants
autre truc qui est intéressant vous avez
des antennes tout autour tout autour
d'un thème 4g et 5g pour le wifi l'idée
c'est quoi en fait c'est de se dire que
si vous tenez vos smartphones comme ça
et que vous que vous tenez votre
smartphone comme ça vous tenez vos
smartphones comme ça comme ça comme vous
voulez cas vous aurez toujours une
antenne qui va venir pouvoir capter
quelques passes a pas venir réduire le
signal dont ça je trouve ça aussi super
bien bien fait bien vu de la part de
rémy ici est pareil ils ont fait un gros
boulot si au niveau du nfc pour étendre
élargir la zone lfc pour que vous soyez
pas sur une petite zone car oui le neuf
c'est pas vous poser c'est assez
pratique autre truc vachement important
sur les smartphones à ce que ses
résultats parce que c'est un usage le
belge c'est ce visage j'ai acheté un
usage très important c'est la partie
photo alors ils nous ont mis à un
grand-angle et un ultra grand-angle dans
les deux cas c'est un 14 50 méga pixels
ouais plutôt pas mal et vous avez sur
votre grand-angle assez la fameuse sony
et mixez la 766 on à utilisation ici
optique et électronique donc pour faire
de la vidéo il n'y a pas de souci et au
niveau du trac grand temps que vous avez
un champ de vision qui va jusqu'à 150
degrés alors on se regarde le reste à
des photos d'ici quelques instants alors
vous avez vous le voyez là vous l'avez
là c'est une petite caméra de maquereau
de 2 mégapixels on regarde aussi les
résultats dans quelques instants et puis
à l'avant elle est juste là les planqués
elle est belle c'est du 30 2 mégapixels
histoire de venir vouloir se shooter
diabate âge même bien je prends en photo
ou j'aime bien moins deux mois le
dépotoir et d'appareils photos donc j'ai
ma caméra ne s'appliquait qu'aux theft
auto qu'est ce que ça raconte regarder
on a le résultat là je vous ai fait
quelques petites photos histoire de vous
montrer de vous illustrer montrer tout
ce qu'on peut faire et l'étendue des
possibilités là on est sur le capteur
principal qu'on va appeler le grand
angle et ensuite on va switcher sur lui
très grand-angle alors attention je
voulais dit ici avec le trac en temps
non pas aller jusqu'à 1 150 degrés ici
c'est pas le cas la 150° je vous
montrerai un peu plus tard un peu plus
loin je ferme en assurant que tous un
peu plus standard probablement du 116 ou
du 120 degrés c'est ce qui me semble en
tout cas être ici le cas on peut venir
jouer mais c'est tout du zoom numérique
parce qu'ici on n'a pas de téléobjectifs
donc on va dire kron p dans l'image
prise par le capteur principal et plus
on va venir sauver et l'image de venir
se dégrade et fatalement jusqu'à 1 x 20
numérique donc on va venir éviter fois
de hockey au delà de ça on n'y va pas
alors ce qu'on voit tout de suite au
niveau de ce capteur principal c'est pas
mauvais mais je trouve qu'en termes
d'image en termes de détails en termes
de couleurs on est un peu en dessous on
va souhaiter ensuite sur du très grand
temps qu'un tout de suite beaucoup plus
terne un peu moins bien et après vous
vous souvenez forcément je vous ai déjà
expliqué comme moi sauf qu'après
principe à ce serait à même colorimétrie
de la même façon la voyez j'ai vraiment
voulu pousser un peu dans ses
retranchements avec un bon contre jour
alors pour autant s'en sort pas mal on
voit bien le dom de face mais on a cette
petite alors je sais pas comment appeler
ça aberration on va dire ça comme ça au
niveau du soleil qui est là et
c'est pas parfait à côté de ça et je le
reconnaître il va quand même plutôt même
faire ressortir la façade et tout le
reste du bâtiment dont bon vous voyez il
ya quand même un boulot algorithmique et
d'arriérés qui est bien pour venir
compenser mais il ya quelques petits
trucs qui font que c'est pas encore
parfait l'ultra grand temps ici et dans
ce cas là n'en parlons pas même si une
fois de plus de produits algorithmique
on vient bientôt récupérer et on vient
pousser un petit peu le trait pour
ajouter un peu plus de un peu plus
d'honnêteté bon quand on vient souvent
mais c'est toujours un peu la même chose
lorsque vous avez des conditions avec
beaucoup de soleil que soleil dans le
tout petit a pas beaucoup mieux on le
voit juste ici c'est quand même
vachement mieux sur l' ultra grand-angle
également voyez c'est quand même pas mal
parce que là on retrouve bien toute
cette brique la couleur le ciel qu'on
voit bien ici on a dû détails par ici
également voit bien les détails dans les
arbres c'est pas mal ultra grand temps
que c'est la même chose et en ont
souvent une fois de plus alors là je
suis venu tester les choses assez
intéressantes ça c'est le 150° il 152
grillons ne vois pourquoi déjà parce que
vous voyez j'ai pas fait gaffe et j'ai
un petit bout de doigts qui traînent ici
et puis on a coté un peu plus d formant
un peu plus arrondies là où quand on va
si vous voulez arriver sur 1 120 ou sans
cesse degré que ça va venir groupe est
légèrement dans l'image pour éviter
cette déformation d'un point de vue
optique voilà ici on la rue on peut même
aller jusqu'à ce qu'on appellera une
photo fischart ace et un mode qui
propose alors faut-il y aller en fichant
je ne suis pas convaincu mais si vous
voulez faire du fichage et bien le
smartphone peut faire nativement et ça
voyez c'est la photo et que lui travaux
l'ensemble standard qui tout de suite
des formes beaucoup moins regarder vous
le voyez là hop là c'est quand même un
peu plus droit pas une photo ici prises
avec votre capteur principal on switch
sur lui très grand-angle et ensuite sur
le 150° voyez tout de suite ça vient
légèrement recourbé et c'est une fois de
plus normal regardez la différence entre
l'ultra grand angle et le 150 degrés et
ensuite le mode fish eye alors ça c'est
intéressant parce qu'en fait vous avez
une caméra de macro mais en fait c'est
pas de la macro c'est du micro
microscopique comme ce qu'on a pu voir
déjà une dernière dans notre temps dans
un autre marque ford en tout cas il est
assez intéressant si vous voulez aller
chercher du point de détail si vous
voulez vraiment vous rapprochez ça c'est
une feuille c'est du détail sur une
seule alors attendez il faut bien se
positionner bien réussir à choper le
bond de taille c'est sur cette file un
donc voyez c'est assez marrant alors
vous pouvez venir zoom et ça doit être
un x 20 et après il ya un x 40 on va
venir ou mais en fait on numérique dans
l'image alors il faut bien trouver sa
position d un côté un peu rigolo je suis
pas content vous qu'on fasse très
régulièrement mais si on veut on peut le
faire regardez on va venir nous mais on
va venir chercher ce qui à l'intérieur
est ce que vous êtes prêt à laisser
partir les bombasses rapprocher voyez on
part quand même de ces petites tâches
lallaing qu'on a donc les à côtés qui
est quand même assez satisfaisant
regarder ça pour autant la qualité tels
raymond bon je suis pas convaincu c'est
un côté un peu un peu rigolo on revient
zoom et enfin 40 dedans on a tout
marrant pour y redécouvrir et se
réapproprier le monde là je voulais fait
la demande et vous est-ce que c'est à
votre avis c'est quoi he has done dans
le mille bah c'est un bout de mur voyage
j'ai posé mon téléphone contre mur et ça
va sortir la caméra celle fille elle est
quand même un peu en dessous pourquoi
déjà on voit qu'au niveau des lumières
c'est un peu plus compliqué on voit
qu'il ya pas de stabilisation optique et
avec moi ça pardonne pas là et là c'est
pareil pas stabilisation alors quand
j'ai réussi à me poser que ça bouge un
petit peu moins eh bien ça va ça va ça
vient d'être par contre le plus bien
derrière voyez bon c'est pas parfait
mais j'avais d'autres photos pour
essayer d'autres choses ça marche bien
quand même en il faut le reconnaître
grand angle ultra grand-angle 150 degrés
et le fisheye alors il ya un autre mode
qui existe qui hélas pas si vous aviez
le voir là bref c'est le mode 3d photo
et mode 3d photo permis de faire
plusieurs trucs qui peuvent être assez
rigolo faire à un mode un petit peu
tourbillon à faire un mode avec comme un
délit zoom alors là je les fais je suis
tout seul donc ce n'est pas évident à
faire avec quelqu'un qui bouge en fait
vous ait quelqu'un en face à vous qui
bouge pas et ça vous faire un effet de
zoom donc la personne et face à vous ne
bougez pas cet incident profondeur en
vidéo bon c'est assez rigolo et si je
peux bien filmé en 8k jusqu'à 24 images
par seconde tout de suite en train de
filmer en cas de cas à 30 images par
seconde mais si je le souhaite le faire
l'un 4k à 30 ou à 60 images par seconde
donc on voit qu'ici de toute façon en
termes de capacités de calcul le
processeur a de quoi faire le taf et que
remy a mis la barre très haute pour
venir aussi draguer les créateurs
contenu parce que je peux venir tenir à
la main comme ça ça va être stabilisé
stabilisation optique également
stabilisation électronique donc je peux
aller vélo gemballa les avec elle très
facilement et ça c'est plutôt bien
juste avant vous donner le prix de ce
film y est c'était de prompt à regarder
rapidement leurs ennemis gt2 parce que
c'est aussi un smartphone qui est
intéressant alors on s'en doutera il en
fera un petit peu moins que le procès
sera aussi un peu moins cher au lieu
d'un sa dragonne huit gènes un indice
comme ça vous avez un sa dragonne 888
qu'est le cendre aegon de l'année
dernière le plus haut de gamme de la
génération précédente qui ira aussi
parfaitement bien vous avez également 8
et douzy gadrat nous avait également une
batterie de 5000 militants perrin vous
avez également de la recharge rapide 65
watts ici c'est un écran super amoled
vous avez un taux de rafraîchissement
qui va jusqu'à 120 hertz vous avez un
taux d'échantillonnage tactile qui va
jusqu'à 1000 hertz on va pas jusqu'à
1400 10 mai jusqu à 1310 vous allez
franchement un tout qui conviendra
parfaitement bien de la 5g également
bref un smartphone très actuel qui
rateraient très bien alors il ya une
petite différence au niveau de la photo
au lieu d'avoir un capteur hulk un
grand-angle de 50 méga pixels vous êtes
sur un 8 mégapixels sinon le grand-angle
c'est le même et la macro c'est la même
écoute et celle fille on a divisé par
deux on est ici sur du 16 mégapixels bon
il faut dire qu'il est quand même
beaucoup moins cher alors les tarifs on
va y aller parce que c'est quand même un
sujet qui vous intéresse énormément sur
le modèle professionnel de remy j'étais
de proue en est alors il ya différentes
paris fin des tarifs de base et 849
euros 99 et souvent il ya des offres
dont je vous avais acheté un coup d'oeil
via le lien que vous avez en bas dans la
description pour trouver ce smartphone
aux meilleurs tarifs tandis que lui il a
le gt2 qui n'est pas pro mais qui est
déjà très très bien son tarif de base
c'est 599 euros 99 a une fois de plus
allez jeter un oeil dans la description
via le lien parce que de temps en temps
il se peut qu'à une offre soit sympa qui
passe par là et qu'il se soit l'occasion
de se faire plaisir et de voilà d'en
profiter dans les meilleures conditions
donc voilà pour ses smartphones je
trouve vraiment intéressant et surtout
moi ce qui m'interesse voyez cette voir
le gros travail que faire nbc la
progression qui font ils viennent
booster les fiches techniques pour vous
dire ok on a des smartphones plus dans
le milieu de gamme mais là on envoie du
gros pack thé avec un smartphone haut de
gamme avec des choses qui conviendront
parfaitement bien que ce soit au niveau
de la faute au niveau de la performance
on s adresser pour personne qui aime tu
contenus multimédias qui vont regarder
du contenu sur un grand écran on va
s'adresser aux personnes qui jouent aux
personnes qui veulent faire des photos
en bref un smartphone très complet pour
tout un chacun et que je trouve vraiment
intéressant leur dernier petit détail
parce qu'il ya plusieurs couleurs on
s'en doutera alors là j'ai la couleur
qu'on appelle le blanc papier ce petit
touche hélas il existe également en
verre papier avec lé même touché mais
également en noir acier plutôt
intéressant à vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez comment vous trouvez
comment vous les trouvez ces rimes gt2
gt2 pro est ce qu'il vaut aïe est-ce
qu'il vous plaise est-ce qu'il vous
botte est ce que vous pourriez vous
laisser tenter et si oui n'oubliez pas
le lien est en bas dans la description
vous andral pour les soit le clou très
bientôt
[Musique]